in 1986 the residents of new High Street
in headington near Oxford woke up to
find there was a new addition to the
road a shark in the roof of number two
it was commissioned by the owner of the
house its protest artwork anti-war
symbolic of bombs crashing down into
buildings and of course English planning
laws do not allow someone to suddenly
install a giant shark sculpture in the
roof in a residential area at least not
without consulting the neighbors first
so in 1986 my dad put a 25 foot five
glass and steel shark through the roof
of his house he just bought his first
house and the first night he moved in he
had planes going overhead who's awoken
by this and in the morning he read the
newspaper and
I suppose saw destroyed houses in Libya
in bond The Story Goes that my dad and
sculptor John Buckley were sat and
drinking celebrating purchased this
house sort of mulling over how to to
deal with the shock of the bombing of
Tripoli they were up for a fight and
they did the shark without playing
Commission in secret that was a sort of
mixed reaction a lot of people were
shocked and didn't quite know what was
going on I think some people thought it
might have been real which is an
eye-opener certainly a funny looking
back a lot of people just loved it and
thought it was brilliant right from the
word go the council obviously were very
much not here thank you and certainly
not without flying permission this is
outrageous so the months and years after
the shark was installed played out
exactly as you would expect the council
said take it down the owner said no it
went to court it took six years to
resolve and the shark was eventually
allowed to stay when a senior British
government official intervened and said
yes this has enough artistic Merit that
as a one-off it can stay and now it's an
icon of the area known around the world
and as far as I can tell generally liked
by the folks around here perhaps a bit
more than the current owner would like
before we get to that though I did have
a couple of more practical questions
about the shark like does it have a head
it doesn't have a head it's just a half
bust of a shark crashing through the
roof I think they cut a crude hole and
dropped that in with a crane initially
and then sort of short it up as soon as
they human they could there was no
preparation obviously because that would
have tipped people off it's fiberglass
with steel reinforcements the steel
struts on the inside connect out through
the ceiling and down into the walls so
it's it's structurally connected it's
it's there to stay it needs repainting
every now and then and there's just
continual checking to make sure
everything's not in tip-tock condition
this year thanks to a nomination from a
presumably well-meaning member of the
public the shark was put on the local
list of Heritage assets now the shark
isn't on the national list of protected
buildings yet it could still be taken
down without breaking the law but local
registration is often the first step to
being on the national list and owning a
listed building is a pretty significant
burden the local government requires you
to keep it in good condition and also
keep it the same and if you don't they
can fix it themselves and Bill you art
just like anything else requires upkeep
and there are news stories that show
that over the last few decades the shark
and this house was sometimes in
extremely poor condition drop shot
through the roof of your house there are
some leakage for others that one might
immediately encounter it turns out it's
very difficult to repair those until
finally my mum ultimately stepped in and
did the whole thing up into I think
quite a nice standard though I've been
renting it out as an Airbnb it's just a
lovely place and it means a lot to me
and I like that people can come and be
sort of close to it and part of it too
so someone put it forward for the Oxford
asset Heritage register on the council
website they say they that there's
absolutely no restrictions placed this
is just for their record keeping but
they do mention that any planning
permission changes will necessarily take
this into consideration I thought this
was an interesting take because well
normally this is here to preserve the
shark but this is controlled through the
planning laws and seems to me you can't
really preserve something that's
specifically that to challenge that that
seems to be completely absurd and to
miss sort of the artistic point which is
is probably the thing you would want to
preserve you're preserving a piece of
art as a bystander I love art like this
where part of the work is how it
interfaces with the world and with
bureaucracy but for the local officials
it must be frustrating because they know
that anything they do to this shark
becomes part of the art part of the
story List It unlisted demand its
removal demand its preservation
deliberately ignore it whatever they do
that's art now I wouldn't want to be in
that position so my dad passed away in
2019 we spoke a little bit about the
listing just before we did he had sort
of mixed feelings on the one hand he'd
been sort of fighting against the
council for like a large portion of his
life on the other hand he sort of had
these considerations about the legacy of
the place and moving forward and like
that they were acknowledging him you've
got this idea that the council have come
around and changed their mind and are
now embracing something they weren't
before
and on the other hand you've got this
this I think slightly more truthful side
which is that these are totally
different counselors that councils that
hated it are all gone and these new ones
although they love it are applying the
same kind of control which is again lies
in the face of the the piece I guess
there's a bit of conflict there that I I
wish he was still here to ask and and
see how it all panned out I think it
would he'd like that we're still talking
about it today very much for now the
shark is not protected not officially in
a few years
who knows